hat der cyberkrieg schon längst begonnen
ziel eines hacker angriffs zu werden das
passiert doch nur großen institutionen
banken behörden oder großen firmen man
selbst läuft vielleicht in die gefahr
phishing mails zu öffnen
na ja leider weit gefehlt jeder
internetnutzer kann opfer einer
hacker-attacke und damit teil einer noch
größeren attacke werden jetzt bei klicks
und science fiction
das wurde vielen nutzern erst kürzlich
bewusst vor allem kunden der telekom
900.000 kunden des unternehmens waren
betroffen ihre route wurden gehackt und
der zugriff auf das internet und
internet abhängige dienste wie tv oder
der festnetzanschluss war ab dann nicht
mehr verfügbar
schon vorher hatte ein internetnutzer
unter dem pseudonym can zu 2007 davor
gewarnt dass bestimmte route durch einen
befehl leicht gekapert und dann für
größere hacker angriffe missbraucht
werden können
und nun war es auch bei der telekom
passiert zunächst waren sich die
techniker und sicherheitsexperten des
konzerns nicht sicher warum bundesweit
die netzaktivität plötzlich gesunken war
die ausfälle wurden mehr biss in der
spitze 900.000 kunden offline waren erst
nach stunden konnten technische probleme
ausgeschlossen werden und am abend des
angriffs waren sich die meisten experten
sicher dass es sich hierbei um eine
cyber-attacke handeln muss die router
sollten zu einem botnetz
zusammengeschlossen werden die
schwachstelle der router ist die
fernwartung über das protokoll wollten
die angreifer die geräte unter ihre
kontrolle bringen
genau wie ist der internetnutzer kennt
zu 2017 für ähnliche geräte vorhergesagt
hatte betroffen waren in diesem fall
geräte des herstellers arkadien
zwar konnten die geräte dem angriff so
gesehen wieder stehen denn die
schad-software konnte sich nicht
installieren
dennoch fielen sie aus auch das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik kurz bsi hatte sie
an die auswertung des hecks gemacht und
so kam man zu dem resultat dass die mail
software mehr hinter der attacke steckt
dieses programm basiert auf linux und
kann mit servern und anderen geräten ein
botnetz herstellen vor einigen wochen
hatte man damit schon eine große ddos
attacke auf die server von netflix
amazon twitter und airbnb durchgeführt
dass die router der telekom ihren dienst
verweigerten lag daran dass die mail ihn
ein update vorgegaukelt hatte nach jedem
standardverfahren versuchten die router
dann die server der telekom zu connecten
dort gab es aber natürlich kein update
die router hing also in einer schleife
und die nutzer waren auf leyen das
problem an dieser attacke ist das
inzwischen nicht nur computer mit dem
internet verbunden sind natürlich sind
auch smartphones und smarties
aber es kommen immer weitere geräte
hinzu die online sind das internet der
dinge wird also zum problem
ein smarter kühlschrank kann genauso
attackiert werden wie eine
überwachungskamera mit
internetverbindung auch wenn die router
der telekom dem angriff mehr oder
weniger standgehalten haben experten
haben festgestellt dass weltweit etliche
andere router das nicht konnten und sich
mit der schadsoftware infiziert haben
leider oft ist cyber security analyst
bei adcubum sagt zitat seit dem
wochenende verzeichnen wir einen
drastischen anstieg von infizierten
geräten rund um den globus speziell aus
dem brasilianischen netz der
telefonica-tochter movistar aber auch
dem das türkische netzbetreibers telekom
sowie von betroffenen routen britischer
und irischer internetnutzer zitat ende
das zeigt auch dass es kein gezielter
angriff auf die deutsche telekom war
sondern im großen stile weltweit
angegriffen wurde auch das bsi sieht in
der vernetzung aller dinge eine große
gefahr wie die behörde in ihrem
lagebericht zur it-sicherheit in
deutschland für 2016 berichtet durch die
vernetzung potenzieren sich die
möglichkeiten für hacker immens auch der
informationsdiebstahl kann so ganz neue
dimensionen erfahren wenn privatleute
fast 24 stunden am tag mit
internetfähigen geräten hantieren sogar
der markt um sich die werkzeuge für
cyber kriminelle handlungen zu besorgen
sei einfacher und professioneller
geworden digitalen währungen wie
beispielsweise bitcoin würden dabei eine
große rolle spielen
cyber attacken sind längst auf einer
professionellen stufe angekommen und
werden vor allem aus dem ausland durch
gut organisierte gruppen durchgeführt
laut des berichts entdeckt das bsi rund
380.000 schadprogramme am tag und es
kann wieder jeden treffen schädliche e
mail anhänge sind längst bekannt und man
könnte meinen niemand öffnete 2016 noch
unbekannte mail anhänge problematisch
ist dabei auf der endnutzer ihm stehen
zwar werkzeuge zur verfügung um sich
gegen mail wer und dergleichen zu
schützen allerdings werden diese laut
bsi sehr oft nur sehr unzureichend oder
falsch eingesetzt oft wird hier durch
den nutzer am falschen ende gespart
kostenlose tools bieten meistens nicht
gegen schutz der heutzutage benötigt
wird wir sind sozusagen schon
mittendrin in einem cyberkrieg hacker
gegen provider und sicherheitsbehörden
und zwischen diesen fronten steht sehr
oft der normale user mit seinen
endgeräten und die steigt ja wie eben
schon gesagt immer weiter an
oft wird auch nicht bemerkt dass ein
gerät teil eines ganzen botnetzes ist
die folgen sind aber dann doch zu spüren
ist kann echt üble folgen haben zum
beispiel wirtschaftliche oder gar
lebensgefährliche bedrohungen
sollte es zum beispiel gelingen
krankenhäuser zu hacken und ja das ist
schon passiert anfang 2016 waren zwei
krankenhäuser nordrhein-westfalen ziel
einer cyber attacke
und wie ist das mit technischen anlagen
vor sechs jahren trank der stadt wurm in
ein iranische atomkraftwerk ein starkes
netz war laut experten wo die erste
schad software die auf industrieanlagen
spezialisiert war es gibt theoretisch
kaum eine grenze für cyberangriffe und
den möglichen schaden der damit
verbunden ist wie seht ihr das
steht uns das schlimmste noch bevor und
wie schützt ihr eure geräte schreibt es
mir in die kommentare und wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann lasst uns gerne
einen daumen nach oben da und ein
kostenloses abo darf einfach hier
klicken
und wenn ihr hier klickt dann kommt er
zu einem video in dem wir uns mit den
eben auch angesprochenen virtuellen oder
digitalen währungen beschäftigen viel
spaß dabei und bis dann